قال مفاوض الامم المتحده اسامي لحقوق
الانسان والكرتون الى مكتب المفوضيه في
كيف اصدر تقريرا يوثقوا مغسله
441 مواطنا الاوكرانيا في شمال وفي محيطها
خلال فتره سيطره القوات الروسيه على تلك
المناطق
وفي نهايه الزياره لاوكرانيا استمرت اربعه
ايام اكد فولكر وجود مؤشرات
وصفها بالقويه على وقوع جرائم حرب في تلك
المناطق
ريبورت اليوم تقريبا
في اجزائهم من ثلاث مناطق في شمال
والتي كانت تحت سيطره الروسيه حتى اوائل
ابريل يوثق التقرير مقتل مدنيين وهم
يقطعون الحطب او وهم يشترون من محاليل
البقاله كانت بطشه المنطقه الاكثر تضررا
ومازلنا نعمل على تاكيد ادعاءات وقوعه
عمليات قتل اضافيه في هذه المناطق وفي
اجزاء من مناطق خارجي واخرصون التي
استعادتها القوه الاخرانيه مؤخرا هناك
مؤشرات قويه على ان عمليات الاعدام
الميدانيه الموثقه في التقرير بشكل جريمه
حرب تتمثلوا في القتل العمد